situé au coeur du quartier chinois ta
phong existe depuis 1989
la boutique a été fondée par le grand
père de lily tran il voulait offrir une
vie meilleure à sa famille et s'assurer
que ses descendants puissent poursuivre
son rêve dit elle mais le développement
immobilier et l'embourgeoisement menace
la communauté de nombreux commerçants et
restaurateurs tente toujours de se
relever après un an et demi de pandémie
depuis quelques mois les représentants
des communautés chinoises de montréal
winnipeg edmonton calgary vancouver et
toronto demande au gouvernement fédéral
un plan pour protéger leur quartier
d'un océan à l'autre elle rêve d'un
statut patrimonial et d'un plan d'action
pour assurer le développement économique
du quartier chinois à toronto
mais la loi municipale est limitée elle
ne protège que les bâtiments
bonne question d'instinct clement pense
préserver le bâtiment mais aussi la la
culture l'événement un centre
communautaire culturel au coeur du
quartier chinois pour avoir au moins
sept places pour the hacker saufs et
protégés et les éléments culturels d'un
espace n'ont aucune protection se désole
le conseiller municipal du quartier et
suggère d'interdire aux propriétaires de
louer des espaces à de grandes chaînes
afin que les petites entreprises
puissent prospérer
à montréal la mairesse y est allé de son
propre plan d'action pour protéger et
relancer son quartier chinois
il ya deux semaines la ville compte
notamment développer des logements
sociaux
offrir un meilleur accès piétonnier au
quartier et accompagner la communauté
dans la création d'une association de
commerçants
un modèle qui selon certains pourrait
inspirer d'autres municipalités
canadiennes à protéger ce patrimoine
ici canif high rise and radio canada
toronto